[Musik]
und jetzt das heute journal
an einem tag der in die geschichte
eingeht als nine eleven wollen sie
klarmachen es geht nicht um zahlen und
daten es geht um menschen deren leben
nicht mehr gelebt werden konnten
[Musik]
es sind zwei
20 jahre es fühlt sich an wie eine
ewigkeit und gleichzeitig als sei es
gestern passiert guten abend wer das
erlebt hat wird nie wieder vergessen wo
sie oder er damals war als die nachricht
kam
als diese bilder um die welt gingen und
man nicht hingucken wollte und nicht
weggucken konnte immer noch nicht
wirklich zu fassen dieser angriff auf
eine stadt ein land und auf uns alle wir
sprechen gleich über die folgen bis
heute erst zeigt claudia bates wie
amerika heute zurückdenkt
[Musik]
in einem anschein von einheit versammelt
sich das land heute unter der flagge der
original flagge des world trade centers
und so zerrissen wie die flagge so ist
auch das land
[Musik]
die hinterbliebenen legen die ewigen
aber offen auf der seele aller die den
elfter september erlebt haben sie
erinnern an ihre angehörigen und an das
land das amerika sein möchte
diese feiglinge haben leben genommen
aber es gibt auch etwas was wir uns
nicht nehmen konnten unseren kampfgeist
unserer erinnerung sie können uns nicht
unsere freiheit nehmen unsere liebe
unser land und sie können nicht die
nehmen die es verteidigen
[Musik]
es ist ein leises erinnern an der
gedenkstätte unter dem neuen world trade
center
blumen und flaggen für die opfer der
anschläge
[Musik]
ein sandstein markiert die absturzstelle
von flug 93 auch von terroristen am 11
september entführt und von heldenhaften
passagieren zum absturz gebracht
hier gedenkt der damalige präsident
george bush der opfer er hatte damals
den krieg gegen den terror ausgerufen
jetzt warnt er auch vor inneren vor
einheimischen terror
es gibt wenig kulturelle
überschneidungen zwischen gewalttätigen
extremisten im ausland und im inland
aber in ihrer missachtung von vielfalt
ihrer geringschätzung menschlichen
lebens in ihrer entschlossenheit
nationale symbole zu schänden darin sind
sie kinder desselben fauligen geistes
und es bleibt unsere pflicht ihnen
entgegen zu treten
hier im pentagon werden gerade die pläne
gemacht wie der krieg gegen den terror
weiter gehen soll nach dem verheerenden
abzug aus afghanistan
denn dort sind es die terroristen von
damals die heute triumphieren und
amerika ist nach dieser niederlage ein
verwirrtes und verwundetes land
der elfter september darf niemals wieder
geschehen aber den zwölften september
hätten wir uns gerne bewahrt sagen viele
amerikaner in einem land das damals
spürte wie alle zusammenstehen und das
heute so gespalten ist und gerade das
debakel erlebt um seinen längsten krieg
unsere korrespondenten in den usa und in
afghanistan sind jetzt live bei uns in
der sendung zunächst m at wissen in new
york über 20 jahre danach wie sehr wird
nine eleven und das desaströse ende des
afghanistan-einsatzes die us politik
jetzt prägen
also das gedenken an den schrecken das
ist natürlich nicht abgehakt aber viele
überlegen doch welche lehren zu ziehen
sind aus diesen 20 jahren das sind in
erster linie 2 also die supermacht usa
überhebt sich wenn sie andere länder
nach ihrem vorbild militärisch und
politisch umgestalten will der präsident
hat ja klar gesagt dass die ära dieser
interventionen vorbei sei und das hat
seinen grund auch in der zweiten lehrer
aus diesen 20 jahren was für ein vorbild
liefert amerika denn es hat vor lauter
kampf gegen den terrorismus zum guten
teil auch nicht gemerkt dass im grunde
genommen da etwas kaputt gegangen ist in
diesem land da sind paranoia und lügen
eingesickert in die demokratie und die
demobilisierung von andersdenkenden
andersdenkenden und auch von menschen
die vermeintlich anders sind vielleicht
eine andere religion haben oder einen
anderen ethnischen hintergrund das hat
eben diese demokratie stark angegriffen
und deswegen ist jetzt die größte gefahr
george bush hat das ja heute auf den
punkt gebracht diese extremismus von
innen im inneren dieses landes wo es hat
ja eben die terroristen vom 11 september
verglichen mit denen die das capitol
gestürmt haben am 6 januar also amerika
muss dringend einige angelegenheiten
selbst erledigen und das wird die die
politik amerikas in den nächsten jahren
natürlich dominieren und dann weiter auf
die andere seite der welt katrin
eigendorf 20 jahre nacheinander levon
weht die taliban flagge wieder über
kabul ist das heute so schlimm es klingt
ein feiertag für die islamisten
man hätte es eigentlich erwarten können
aber es gab von seite der taliban keine
öffentliche äußerung und man hat wohl
auch bewusst darauf verzichtet diesem
tag heute hier als sieg zu inszenieren
der grund
afghanistan steht vor enormen
wirtschaftlichen problemen das
gesundheitssystem steht kurz vor dem
kollaps und die taliban sind darauf
angewiesen dass die usa all die gelder
die dort noch liegen die zentralbank
gelder die hauptsächlich in den usa
eingefroren sind frei gibt das land ist
ebenso darauf angewiesen internationale
hilfsgelder zu bekommen ansonsten wird
es nicht möglich sein das land vor einem
wirtschaftlichen kalt zu bewahren und
das ist das was im moment für die
taliban wichtig ist deswegen dieses
auftreten heute dass das relativ klein
gefahren wird auch wir journalisten
merken hier dass die taliban versuchen
relativ versöhnliche töne im moment an
zu schlagen denn man weiß man ist auf
internationale kooperation angewiesen
will nicht wieder zu einem paria staat
werden wie das ja in den 90er jahren der
fall war hat sich gedanken nach kabul
und nach new york
und damit hier bei uns nach deutschland
und hinein in unseren wahlkampf man kann
davon ausgehen dass armin laschet genau
weiß wie es um seine umfragewerte steht
und seine chancen der nächste
bundeskanzler zu werden aber wozu hat
man denn parteifreunde kollege söder von
der schwesterpartei csu erhöht
jedenfalls schon mal vorsichtshalber den
druck wenn es noch eine chance gibt den
trend zu brechen hat er gesagt dann an
diesem wochenende laschet musste also
klar sein was von ihm erwartet wird
heute auf dem csu-parteitag stefan
leifert
[Applaus]
unseres künftigen kanzler als armin
laschet
ein bisschen ungläubig blickt der
kanzlerkandidat schon als applaus und
armin armin rufe nach seiner rede nicht
mehr verstummen
fast neun minuten beifall doppelt so
viel wie für söder gestern 50 minuten
dauert der flirt armin laschet mit den
delegierten eine mischung aus
streicheleinheiten für die csu seele und
warnung vor rot rot grüner instabilität
in entscheidenden momenten muss man kurs
halten und für diesen kurs stehen cdu
und csu und aus dieser absicht heraus
will ich bundeskanzler der
bundesrepublik deutschland werden mit
klarem kurs zu überzeugen
laschet holt weit aus versucht die große
unions erzählung die seinem wahlkampf
bisher fehlt in wallung kommt der
parteitag aber als es frontal gegen olaf
scholz geht laschet attackierte ihn
wegen der razzia im finanzministerium
und wie scholz damit umgehen in einem
moment wo eine
staatsanwaltschaft auf richterliche
entscheidung ein ministerium durchsucht
an in deutschland einmaliger vorgang ist
die richtige reaktion zu sagen wir
helfen der staatsanwaltschaft und nicht
die reaktion zweifel am rechtsstaat zu
sehen das hilft den populisten wenn man
so agiert
es ist kein neuer armin laschet es ist
eine andere csu die in nürnberg mit
ihrer begeisterung überrascht als hätte
es die sticheleien und feindseligkeiten
nie gegeben schließt die csu kurzerhand
die rein
als ich bin sehr positiv überrascht er
war super leidenschaftlich sehr
authentisch und hat die dinge auf den
punkt gebracht toll erwartet hätte sich
dass es dass es am ende so mitreißend
war ehrlich gesagt ich bin schon ein fan
von ihm geworden das hätte ich nicht von
mir gedacht
olaf scholz lässt all das unbeeindruckt
weder die attacke neben die spd noch die
gegen ihn selbst entlocken mehr als
einen satz ich kenne bemerkenswert dass
cdu
csu offenbar keine eigenen themen mehr
hat
in nürnberg reicht es und die csu
hinterlasse zu versammeln dass die
begeisterung für den eigenen kandidaten
überhaupt eine nachricht ist zeigt in
welch schwieriger lage sich die union
befindet
und jetzt weitere wichtige nachrichten
an diesem samstagabend von gundula in
warschau haben bundeskanzlerin merkel
und ministerpräsident morawski bei
mehreren strittigen themen auf
versöhnliche töne gesetzt so solle der
konflikt um die polnische justizreform
in politischen gesprächen mit der eu
gelöst werden erklärte merkel gemeinsam
mit moravetz kippte sie heftige kritik
an belarus es sei inakzeptabel wehrlose
flüchtlinge an die eu außengrenzen
bringen zu lassen merkel gedachte in
warschau auch der opfer des zweiten
weltkriegs der 1939 mit dem überfall
nazi deutschlands auf polen begonnen
hatte im tarifkonflikt bei der bahn
prüft die lokführergewerkschaft gdl das
neue angebot des konzerns und hält noch
offen ob sie zu verhandlungen bereit ist
die bahn macht offenbar verschiedene
zugeständnisse und hat eine neue entgelt
komponente vorgelegt mit dem ziel einen
weiteren streik abzuwenden
mehrere tausend menschen haben in berlin
gegen zu hohe mieten und für mehr
wohnraum demonstriert konkret gefordert
wurden eine neue wohnungsbaupolitik ein
bundesweiter mieten deckel sowie die
enteignung großer immobilienkonzerne zu
dem protest aufgerufen hatten der
berliner mieterbund und das sogenannte
bündnis gegen verdrängung und
mietenwahnsinn
alt bundespräsident gauck hat corona
impfgegner deutlich kritisiert in
rostock nannte er essen bekloppt sich
nicht impfen zu lassen das impf tempo in
deutschland lässt derzeit nach nur 62
prozent sind vollständig geimpft in der
dänischen hauptstadt kopenhagen besuchen
am abend zehntausende konzerte und gehen
aus gestern waren in dänemark alle
corona beschränkungen aufgehoben worden
wegen der hohen impfquote dort
es ist eine gute zeit fürs kino es war
noch nie so lebendig und vital wie jetzt
sagt der direktor des film festivals in
venedig und während man sich noch die
augen reibt und denkt okay als film
festspielchefin diesen zeiten muss man
berufsoptimist sein legt er noch mal
nach es sieht fast so aus als habe die
pandemie auf eine gewisse art die
kreativität der filmemacher angeregt wir
sind gespannt heute hat venedig seinen
goldenen löwen für den besten film
verliehen andreas postel ist dort
wer clever ist zurück auf dem roten
teppich in venedig internationale stars
starke frauen und auf der leinwand ein
spiegelbild unserer welt mit all seiner
liebe und brutalität den preis für die
beste weibliche hauptrolle geht an
penélope cruz und ihre rolle im neuesten
film von altmeister pedro almodóvar
ich habe den preis für einen film mit
ihm gewonnen es ist eine besondere
beziehung zwischen uns herr ist teil
meiner familie
in madras paralleles bringen zwei frauen
am selben tag kinder auf die welt die
gleich nach der geburt vertauscht werden
hintergründig geht es ein mode warm die
geschichte der mutter die ihre söhne im
spanischen bürgerkrieg verloren haben
starke frauen für die penelope cruz eine
rolle spielt die unter die haut geht
[Applaus]
erneut werde ich die jury eine weibliche
regiearbeit mit dem begehrten goldenen
löwen in das ereignis zeigt die
französische filmemacherin den konflikt
einer jungen frau die um einen
schwangerschaftsabbruch weil sie als
studentin und ihre berufliche
veröffentlichung fürchtet
ich bin sehr stolz darauf eine frau zu
sein in der reihe der großen
regisseurinnen zu stehen und über unsere
filme zu sprechen das ist
außergewöhnlich und vielleicht ja gerade
ein zeichen unserer zeit
bester männlicher schauspieler wird
überraschend schon aquila für das
philippinische korruptions drama on the
job sie müssen darin spielt er einen
journalisten der das mysteriöse
verschwinden seiner kollegen untersucht
außer konkurrenz brachten ben affleck
mit jennifer lopez matt damon und star
regisseur ridley scott hollywood flair
auf den lido und das mit einem
relevanten historien-drama opulent
inszeniert erzählt sehr aktuell aus
verschiedenen perspektiven den kampf um
gerechtigkeit nach einer vergewaltigung
im mittelalterlich frankreich eine wahre
begebenheit in der eine frau sich gegen
die macht der männer über frauen wert
kino ist essentiell und deshalb müssen
wir es am leben erhalten der wichtigste
punkt den man will eh nicht zu schreiben
muss ist seine unterstützung für das
kino wenn das kino den anspruch hat der
spiegel unserer welt zu sein dann hat
das älteste filmfestival der welt seinem
ruf in venedig alle ehre gemacht und
wir haben noch den üblichen samstag
service wetteraussichten und lotto die
gewinnzahlen lauten ohne gewähr 6 23 25
33 34 43 superzahl 7 mehr auf lotto zdf
de und im zdf text das wetter wird
morgen am sonntag noch mal etwas
wechselhaft bevor sich die sonne dann
wieder mehr durchsetzt so auch schon
morgen im süden nördlich des mains
allerdings überwiegen die wolken
vereinzelt kann es auch schauer geben im
norden lebhafter westwind und 19 bis 25
grad zu wochenbeginn viel sonne erste
schauer und gewitter am dienstag im
westen am mittwoch zieht ein regengebiet
von west nach ost
und alles vom sport jetzt gleich im
sportstudio so ist es gut oder und
morgen natürlich ist rielle tag im zdf
und auch bei uns bis dann in hallen noch
einen angenehmen restlichen samstag
haben die schönen sonntag
[Musik]